Hello, folks.
Welcome to the
neuroanatomy
lecture on blood
-brain barrier,
meninges, CSF,
and ventricles.
My name is Vinci
Matthew. I am one
of your academic
medicine scholars
on the research
track. Some of you
guys know me from
last semester.
And I want to thank
Dr. Grubashek, who
has given me the
opportunity to give
this lecture and
mentor me through this.
So in this lecture,
we'll cover
a broad variety
of topics.
I know neuroanatomy
is this huge topic
that some of you guys
might fear, but I
have tried to make
this lecture as simple
as it can be and made
it clinical, which
I guess keeps everybody
kind of focused
and also prepares
you for the boards.
Here are my references.
I want you guys
to focus on the Nolte's,
the human brain,
which is your
primary source for
neuroanatomy, and the
first aid, USMA Step 1.
So this is when you guys
should kind of start
using your first
aid with the
lecture studying,
just so that you
guys get familiar
with the terms
used, and just the
book in general.
I have also included
a picture of the first
aid in the corners of
certain slides that
just means that those
slides are heavily
tested on step one and
level one as well as
those will be more
clinically relevant stuff
that you guys might
see in the comp as
well here are your
session objectives um i
would read through it
by yourself but they're
self-explanatory if
you guys are able to
go through this at
the end of the lecture
and say yep, got it,
got it, got it, got
it, then you are good
to go for my lecture.
So I want to start
the lecture by looking
at a clinical question.
I'll have some
questions throughout
that we'll come back to.
So take a minute,
read this question,
and we will
come back to it.
So we'll start by
talking about various
central nervous
system barriers.
So these are two
very rudimentary
but yet informative
pictures that gets
you guys thinking
of the level of
microscopic anatomy
and physiology
we'll cover in the
next few sides.
So in this left picture
that we have, you
see the brain kind
of being protected by
this invisible glowy
barrier. So this barrier
may be invisible. When
I talk about barrier,
I'm talking about
blood-brain barrier.
It maybe is invisible,
but it plays a
critical role in
maintaining the delicate
environment within our
central nervous system.
It protects our brain
from potential harm
while carefully regulating
what can and cannot
enter. So you can
imagine it as being a
security checkpoint
so advanced that it
screens every single
molecule that enters your
brain, allowing
nutrients, essential
compounds to pass while
blocking out harmful
agents. That's essentially
the job of what
blood-brain barrier
does. It's a structure
built with purpose,
evolved over millions
of years to protect
our most vital organs.
And there are three
different barriers that
we'll cover in the
next couple of slides.
So essentially, there
are three different
central nervous system
barriers. We have the
blood-brain barrier,
the blood cerebrospinal
fluid barrier, and
the arachnoid barrier.
All organisms with a
well-developed central
nervous system have a
blood-brain barrier.
In the brain and
the spinal cord of
mammals, including
humans, the blood-brain
barrier is formed by
endothelial cells that
form the walls of the
capillaries. A second
interface is formed by
the epithelial cells
of the choroid plexus
facing the cerebrospinal
fluid which
constitutes the blood
CSF barrier as you can
see in this picture.
And the third interface
is provided by the
avascular arachnoid
epithelium which underlies
the dura in the
arachnoid membrane, the
arachnoid matter, and
completely encloses
the CNS. So these
three layers completes
the seal between the
extracellular fluids of
the the central nervous
system, and the rest
of the body. So
basically, separating the
interstitium of the
brain from the blood.
So what exactly
is the blood-brain
barrier? Well, it is a
selectively permeable,
semi-permeable
membrane between the
blood and the
interstitium of the brain.
and it is
composed of three
main structures.
You have the
endothelial cells,
so here is a
schematic of the blood
-brain barrier and this
is the longitudinal
view. So this side is
the apical side of
the lumen of the blood
vessel and this is the
brain interstitium. So
we're trying to prevent
movement of stuff
from inside the blood
into the blood vessel
into the brain
interstitium. So going from
lumen of the blood vessels
into the interstitium,
we have three
structures that are
important to understand.
We have the endothelial
cells, you have the
pericytes, You can see
it here in the green
and in the green here.
And you have the
astrocyte end feet in
the blue here and
the blue here. And
you also can see
the glial cells, the
astrocytes, microglia,
neurons. They also
participate in forming
the blood-brain
barrier from the
interstitial side,
all of which their
job is to shield
the brain from
toxic substances,
filter harmful
compounds from the
brain to the
bloodstream, and
supply brain tissue
with nutrients.
The key feature
of the blood
-brain barrier
is your tight
junctions, or the
zona occludens.
These are located
between the cerebral
endothelial cells, so
you can see in this
schematic, you see the
ZO3, ZO2, ZO1, those are
your zona occludens,
and they significantly
reduce the permeation
of polar solutes
through the paracellular
divisional pathways
between the endothelial
cells from the blood
plasma to the brain
extracellular fluid.
Here on the right is a
transmission electron
microscope of the
two endothelial cells
side to side, and you can
see this tiny opening.
It's basically the
tight junction that's
connecting them,
patching them together,
essentially
completely restricting
that paracellular
motion of
ionic solutes and
big macrosolutes.
And you have the
cloudin and occludin
transmembrane proteins,
which are involved
as well, and they're
connected to the
cytoskeleton through
the zona occludins.
there are various
disease processes that
breaks down the blood
-brain barrier so if
you compare the schematic
here the healthy
blood-brain barrier
versus the blood-brain
barrier breakdown you
see that there are
different processes
involved so you have
the altered paracellular
and trancellular
transport decreased
tight junction protein
expression so you can
imagine those If the
tight junctions does
not exist, then there
is an increased
paracellular transport.
You have detached
and swollen
astrocytes, demyelination
of the neurons,
basement membrane
thinning, activated
microglia, which
basically eats up
some of the cells,
destroyed cells.
So these are different
processes to the cell
components that make
up the blood-brain
barrier. And we see all
of these in different
states, such as tumor,
which can cause that
inflammatory response,
and vasogenic edema.
Anytime you have edema
around the brain, it
kind of stretches that
tight junction, and
you're basically kind
of opening it up at
that gap. So then
there's more of that
paracellular transport
that happens. There's also
angiogenesis during the
tumor, where the new
blood vessels essentially
permeate through
the blood-brain barrier,
breaking it down.
during traumatic
brain injury, it can
either be an actual
insult to the blood-brain
barrier, breaking
it up, or the
inflammation that
ensues. During multiple
sclerosis, you have the
demyelination of the
central nervous system.
Thus, you're kind
of losing that extra
protective layer.
Alzheimer's disease,
you have the
deposition of beta
amyloids, again,
causing that
inflammatory response.
Intraventricular
hemorrhage,
also causing that
edema process,
stretching the
tight junctions.
So all of these then
destroys that sterile
environment of the
brain, wherein you
have the CSF, which
is inside the, within
the blood-brain
barrier. The CSF is a
ultrafiltrate of the
plasma of the blood.
So then when you have
that breakdown of
blood-brain barrier,
you see a normalization
of the contents
within CSF and plasma
of the blood which
is never good because
now the brain is
not sterile anymore.
Now that we have gone
through the contents
of the blood-brain
barrier and some of the
disease states that
does damage these,
coming back to this
question, it should be
clear that the answer
is zona occludens or
the tight junctions
that we talked about.
The blood-brain
barrier is generally a
lipophilic or hydrophobic
barrier. So it generally
only allows lipid
-soluble substances into
it. There are some
exceptions where it
does allow very tiny
positively charged molecules.
So the idea is the
more lipid-soluble
a substance, the more
permeability it will
have for the blood
-brain barrier. And this
concept is very important
for pharmacology.
An example I have here
is the use of levodopa
in Parkinson's
disease. So Parkinson's
disease, as you guys
know, is a disease of
decreased dopaminergic
neurons in your
substantia ***** pars
compacta. So the treatment
for it is to deliver
dopamine into the
central nervous system.
However, as you can
see here, dopamine
is a polar substance,
but adding a carboxyl
group into dopamine
makes it levodopa and
makes it non-polar. So
that's actually what we
use for the treatment
of Parkinson's disease.
So the levodopa
being non-polar can
********* the blood-brain
barrier and can go
into the brain and then
inside it, inside
the brain, there is a
decarboxylate that converts
into dopamine and can
then be delivered and
used as a treatment.
Another example is
the use of or the lack
of use of aminoglycosides
in meningitis.
Meningitis is often
caused by, in adults, gram
-negative organisms.
And as you guys know,
aminoglycoside is a great
drug for gram-negative
bacteria. However,
you'll never see
aminoglycosides being given
for meningitis because
it is a highly polar
substance and will
not be able to *********
the blood-brain barrier
enough to treat the
bacteria. So what we
see being used is
vancomycin plus ceftriaxone,
both of which has
lipid solubility and
can thus ********* the
blood-brain barrier
and treat meningitis.
So you guys might be
wondering why we go
into the details of the
cellular parts of the
blood-brain barrier. This
is why. You need to
understand why the
clinical medicine that
we do is the way it is.
Here's another
clinical question.
Pause the lecture and
see if you can answer it.
We will come back to it.
We talked in length
about how the blood-brain
barrier fully covers
the brain and protects
the interstitium of
the brain from the
blood. But there are
special regions that
lack the blood-brain
barrier, and these are
called the circumventricular
organs. These
include the median eminence
here that's posterior
to the hypothalamus.
You have the
posterior pituitary,
also called the
neurohypophysis.
You have the organum
vasculosum of the
lamina terminalis,
situated in the wall of
the lamina terminalis,
which is basically
the anterior wall of
the third ventricle.
You have the sub
-fornical organ, which is
posterior to the fornix,
aptly named. You have
the pineal gland,
which is a gland that
secretes the melatonin
and creates the circadian
rhythm. And finally,
you have area postrema
situated in the caudal
medulla. And these
regions, because they
lack the blood-brain
barrier, are prone
to rapid transmission
of biochemical
influences. So we'll talk
about how some of this
affects us in general.
So it's important
to understand what
these structures are
and their physiology,
because during
certain contrast
-enhanced imaging,
so for example,
in this MRI flare
with contrast,
you can see on the
left side, there is
some contrast enhancement.
So these white
areas that you're
seeing that are lighting
up. So if you don't
know what these
structures are, now
you know these are the
circumventricular
organs. So you have the
subfornical organ,
the organovascularism
of the lamina terminalis,
median eminence,
neurohypophysis, and
the pineal gland.
Because they don't
have the blood-brain
barrier, you can have
contrast enhancement that
you wouldn't see in
other places. And if
you didn't know what
these structures were
and that they lacked
blood-brain barrier,
you could mistake them
for actual pathology
during your radiological
imaging. This
actually happened to
me where pineal gland
generally gets enhanced
during MRI because of
its lack of blood-brain
barrier, and I thought
that was a neoplastic
enhancement. So
again, important to
understand the anatomy
and the cellular
physiology of these organs.
One of the more important
circumventricular
organs for you guys
to know for the
exam and for the boards
in general is area
postrema, also called
the emetic center.
Emesis means vomiting.
So the area postrema
located in the caudal
medulla is our emetic
center. So molecules
that are given in the
periphery that are
toxic or can induce
emesis, it can pass
through because there's no
blood-brain barrier in
the area postrema. it
can bind there and
induce the vomiting
reflux. So we talked about
how levodopa is given
for Parkinson's
treatment as it can cross
the blood-brain
barrier. However, in the
perforate, often
levodopa can be converted
into dopamine because
there are decarboxylase
in the perforate,
and it can thus get
converted into dopamine
and bind to the
area postrema. And
dopamine is an emesis
-inducing agent, so
it can bind to the
dopaminergic receptors
and cause emesis.
And this often happens
in about 30% of the
patients who, Perkinson's
patients who take
levodopa. So what we
can do is add carbidopa,
which is a decarboxylase
inhibitor in the
perforate. Thus, the
levodopa stays as levodopa
and doesn't get
converted to dopamine and
help relieve the nausea
and vomiting that
happens through the
binding in area pastrema.
so now you guys should
be able to answer
this question without
any difficulty
so the circumventricular
organ that we're
talking about here
is area postrema we
talked about the blood
csf barrier which is
formed by the epithelial
cells of the choroid
plexus also called the
specialized epindymo
cells which is a type
of glial cell so here
we have the csf lumen
inside And then you
have the choroid plexus
epidemal cells that,
again, has that tight
junctions creating a
seal between the adjacent
epithelial cells.
And then you have the
lumen of the blood
vessel. So what happens
in hydrocephalus,
especially chronic
hydrocephalus, hydrocephalus
is a buildup of CSF
within the ventricles.
We'll talk about it in
the coming slides. So
this ventricle, I don't
expect you guys to look
at it and see that
this is hydrocephalus.
But over time, you'll
be able to pick
that up. You'll look
at this MRI and see,
okay, this ventricle
is large. You have
ventriculomegaly. And
that's because there
is buildup of
hydrocephalus. There's
buildup of CSF. It's
not flowing properly.
And what happens
is that because
there's so much fluid
buildup, it stretches
that tight
junctions of the
epithelial cells of
the choroid plexus,
the ependymal cells.
So that creates a
leaky paracellular CSF
flow into the brain
parenchyma. And what
ends up happening is
that when you look at
the MRI, especially,
you almost see
like an enhancement
around the ventricles.
And that's basically
fluid, the CSF flowing
through the ependymia
into the parenchyma.
So that's just
edema that you're
seeing, and that's called
the trans-ependymal
CSF flow. This is
a classic pimping
question you'll see in
your neurology or
neurosurgery rotation.
Now we'll switch
gears and talk about
different layers
from superficial to
deep, starting
from the scalp, the
skull, different
layers of the meninges,
and then the different
compartments,
intracranial compartments,
where we can have
potential bleeds.
So starting with the
scalp, the scalp is the
skin and the subcutaneous
tissue that covers
the neurocranium, the
skull. It has five
layers that you can use
the mnemonic scalp, S
-C-A-L-P, to memorize.
And the five
layers, all of which
combined, has great
vascular supply, which
explains why when
you have a small
cut or laceration,
it bleeds profusely.
So the most outer
layer is the skin
that is usually
covered with
hair and has great
vascular supply.
As you go in, you have
the subcutaneous tissue
or the connective
tissue, which is a thick
layer, again, with
vascular supply. um
going in you have
what's called the galea
aponeurosa um this might
be a newer word but that's
it's basically the
aponeurosis of the
muscle muscular layer
um uh where the muscles
the aponeurosis of the
muscles attach um and
this is the strongest
layer of the of the
skin of the scalp um
and um afterwards going
deeply you have the
loose connective tissue
which is
basically a sponge
-like layer of air
roller tissue.
It allows free movement
of the first three
layers over the underlying
pericranium, which
is now the deepest
portion of the scalp.
The pericranium, also
called the periosteum,
is a dense fibrous
connective tissue that
overlays the skull.
So anytime you do any
kind of neurosurgical
procedure, you cut
through all of these
layers and when you're
trying to put the sutures
back up you actually
do two different
layers. You usually
first suture up the
galea and then you take
the connective tissue
with the skin. So
these are important for
surgical procedures.
Deep to the periosteum
or the pericranium we
have the cranium or
the skull. The skull
is composed of flat
bones. So the outer table
of the skull is a
cortical flat bone. And
then you have the inner
surface made of spongy
bone, which is more a
roller and has veins
going through it called
the diploic vein.
And then the more
deeper inner table
is again composed
of cortical bone. So
you kind of have this,
look at the CT scan
in the bone window,
you kind of have this
wafers, chocolate wafers
configuration where
you have the outer
cortical bone, inner
spongy bone, and the
inner table, inner
cortical bone. And
this is actually super
important. Again,
when it comes to doing
craniotomies for
neurosurgical procedure, you
actually have a bar hole
drill that actually,
it's a automatic
pressure sensor drill.
You put it in to make
a hole in the skull,
the drill actually
senses the outocortical
bone, the inner spongy
bone, and when it
gets to the inner
table, inner cortical
bone, right at there,
it stops so that you
don't, you know, drill
through the brain. It
automatically pressure
senses and stops.
Deep to the periosteum,
you have three
layers of membrane
collectively known as the
meninges, which
wraps around both the
brain and the spinal
cord, with the cranial
meninges specifically
referring to the
section that covers the
brain. From superficial
to deep, the layers
are dura mater,
arachnoid mater,
and pia mater. Mater
in Latin means
mother. So you can
see in this
picture, the cranial
meninges, you have
the two layers of the
dura, periosteal
and meningeal dura.
Inside it, you have the
arachnoid mater, and
then right on top of
the brain parenchyma,
you have the pia mater.
Same thing covering
the spinal cord. You
have the dura mater,
you have the
arachnoid mater,
and you have
the pia mater.
Let's talk about these
three layers in depth
now. So the superficial
meningeal layer is
the dura mater. Dura
meaning hard. And as
the name suggests, it
is the hardest of the
meningeal layers. So
there's two layers of
the dura mater. You
have the periosteal dura
that always attaches
to the skull from the
inside, fully adheres to
the skull, and attaches
to it at specifically
the suture lines.
And then the
inner layer is the
meningeal dura or
the dura propria that
is closer to the
arachnoid matter.
And the space between
them is like a
potential space
that usually doesn't
open up, but you'll
see them more during
intra-op neurosurgical
procedures.
Sometimes you try
to separate them.
But they do get separated
to make the channels
that makes up the
sinuses. So for example,
if you look at the
diagram here, you can
see the superior
sagittal sinus, which is
formed by the periosteal
dura completely
attaching to the cranium,
but the meningeal dura
separates here and
comes down to form that
foc cerebri. And that
opening between the
periosteal dura and the
meningeal dura, that
is actually your
superior sagittal sinus.
Deeper to the meningeal
dura or dura propria,
you have the second
layer of meninges
called the arachnoid
matter, arachnoid meaning
spider-like, and the
membrane actually
looks like spider webs.
And when you look at
it inside the brain
intra-op, it almost
looks like this gel
-like membrane that moves
with the CSF as the
CSF is present in the
subarachnoid space and
it's this vispy thin
membrane and deeper
to that is your even
softer pia mater pia
meaning soft and it
directly adheres to the
brain parenchyma and you
can see that you can
separate the arachnoid
and the pia because
the pia actually goes
into all the sulci
so as you open up the
gyri of the of the
brain in neuroanatomy
you'll see that you have
these little troughs
that are your sulci,
the P actually goes
into the troughs and
forms that very thin
membrane over the brain
parenchyma. And forming
these different
layers, you have three
clinical significant
spaces or potential
spaces where you can
have bleeds. So in the
next few sites, we'll
talk about those spaces
and what kind of
bleeds happen in there.
So the first potential
space that can
happen within the brain
from superficial is
your epidural space.
So we talked about
the two layers of the
dura. You have the
periosteal dura and
meningeal dura. So the
epidural space is epi
on top or above the
dura. So it's the
space between the
cranium and the periosteal
dura. And you can
form bleeds over there.
And usually it is
due to the injury
to middle meningeal
artery. So these are
very big pulsatile
arteries that travel
in the groove of the
skull, above the dura,
right on the skull.
They are branches of
the internal maxillary
artery, which comes
off of the external
carotid artery. So
bleeds of the middle
meningeal artery from
high-speed trauma can
cause buildup of blood
in that space, in the
epidural space, causing
epidural hematoma.
The next cavity,
moving more deeper,
is subdural space,
sub, below the
dura. So this is
a space between
meningeal dura and
arachnoid mater.
And these are, you
can have bleeds
in this space
creating subdural
hematoma. And these
are usually formed
by the injury to
bridging veins.
Bridging veins are
tiny veins that travel,
traverses the dura
to get outside from
inside the brain to
outside the dura. And the
injury to these brains
can cause chronic
venous bleed, causing
subdural hematomas.
And finally, the more
deeper space that
you can have is the
subarachnoid space,
subarachnoid, below
the arachnoid, within
that arachnoid space
where the CSF flows.
And a bleed in this
region usually causes
what's known as
subarachnoid hemorrhage.
And these are usually
from aneurysm rupture
of aneurysms from
your arteries that
foams the circle of
villus that we will talk
about in the
cerebrovascular anatomy
lecture. All of which,
all of this we'll
cover in deep in the
pathology and the
cerebrovascular anatomy
lecture that I will be
giving in next week
or so for you guys.
so we have these two
important dura folds
that creates separation
of different parts
of the brain so I want
you guys to take a
look focus on this
picture over here so you
see the left cerebral
hemisphere the right
cerebral hemisphere and
you see the cerebellum
so there is this
sheet that's that is
separating the left and
right hemisphere and
there's another sheet
that's separating the
cerebrum from the
cerebellum. So the sheet
that is separating
the two hemispheres of
the cerebrum, they are
called the fox cerebri.
So the fox cerebri
is basically the
enfolding of your meningeal
dura. Remember I said
the periosteal dura
always attaches to the
cranium, whereas the
meningeal dura separates
from the periosteal
dura, comes inside
and forms this, runs
through the longitudinal
fissure or the
interhemispheric fissure,
fissure means big
separation, and creates
this dural sheet
called the foc cerebri.
And then it attaches
again, comes back and
attaches back to the
perioseal dura. And that
separation is what
creates that superior
sagittal sinus that I
mentioned before, which
we will talk about later
in the cerebrovascular
anatomy lecture.
So that enfolding,
that sickle-shaped
enfolding of the meningeal
dura is the foc
cerebrae that separates
the two cerebrum. And
you can see that clearly
here as well. So
you see this is the
superior sagittal
sinus, that's the venous
structure, that is
created by that meningeal
dura coming inside and
you see that sheet,
that dura sheet
running between that
interhemispheric longitudinal
fissure separating
your right cerebrum.
from the left cerebrum.
And then it
also runs down.
So you have the
periosteal dura again
covering here. And the
meningial dura separates
again laterally,
comes in to separate
your cerebrum from the
cerebellum. So that
sheet of meningial dura
coming in to separate
that, that's called
your tentorium
cerebelli. Tent, meaning
it looks like a tent.
Tentorium cerebelli.
And again, here, the
periosteal dura is
fully attaching to the
cranium, where the
meningeal dura is coming in,
and you create another
sinus from that
opening, that channel,
that is your transfer
sinus, again, we'll talk
about that in later.
And you have the foc
cerebri coming down,
attaching and connecting
with the tentorium
cerebellae midline,
and you have another
channel that's created
via a structure,
that's your straight
sinus, which we also
will talk about in
the future lectures.
The foc cerebri
anteriorly attaches to
your cristo-galli
of the ethmoid bone,
which we talked about
when we mentioned the
olfactory nerves,
right? The fibers of
it runs through that.
And posteriorly,
the foc cerebri attaches
to the tentorium
cerebelli. Whereas the
tentorium cerebelli
attaches to what's
called the clinoid
process of the spinoid
bone. and posteriorly
it attaches to the
occipital bone.
So what are the
clinical implications
of understanding
these dual folds?
It's important to
understand because
you have brain
herniations that happen
around them. Brain
herniation meaning
protrusion or
extrusion of parts of
the brain through
some kind of space.
So remember the skull
is a closed space. It
is tiny and closed space
and does not accommodate
a lot of volume
changes. so in case of
a bleed so let's say
an injury to an artery
or a chronic venous
bleed injury to a vein
or some kind of
neoplastic or inflammatory
lesions these are space
occupying lesions in
the brain and these are
new new volume changes
in the brain which
means the skull does
not have space to
accommodate it which means
something has to move
around and what is it
something that moves
around the brain parenchyma
itself it will get
compressed and it will
start protruding
through where are the
spaces? And the spaces
are around the fox cerebri
and tentorium
cerebellum. So there are
three important herniations
that you guys must
know for the exam and
for your board exams.
So A is pointing to
transtentorial herniation,
to transtentorium
through the tentorium.
So you have the
tentorium cerebellum
cerebellum and trans
around it. So you have
what's called the
medial portion of the
temporal lobe. So here
is your temporal lobe,
right? This is your
temporal lobe. This
is the frontal lobe.
So the medial portion
of the temporal lobe
is called the uncus
that you guys will
learn. And when there
is some lesion, some
bleed, some neoplasm,
some space-occupying
lesion in the same
side, then it will
compress on the brain
there, and your uncus
will herniate down through
the tentorium
cerebellum. um the second
kind is the transforaminal
or tonsillar
herniation so foramen
uh meaning the foramen
magnum the big opening
where the spinal
cord goes through um
a lesion in that area
can herniate or
protrude the tonsils of
the cerebellum down
through the foramen
magnum causing tonsillar
or transforaminal
herniation and finally
you have the sephalcine
or the cingulate
herniation this is the
most common one, that
is the herniation of
the cingulate gyrus
right here, that gyrus
that runs on top of
your corpus callosum
that will herniate
down the fox cerebri.
So the most common
of the brain
herniations that we
talked about is the
sub-fallicine herniation
or the cingulate
herniation. But
in your clinical
rotations, you will
often just hear it
being referred to
as midline shift.
The attending will
say, oh, there's an
epidural hematoma
causing mass effect. The
midline shift is five
millimeter. So the midline
shift is basically
measured in a CT
scan. So you have the
CT of the head here
looking at the right
side of the brain here.
So remember on a
radiology image, CT, MRI,
MRV, the right and
left is always shifted.
So this is the right
side of the brain. and
you can see this cartoon
showing the same.
So there's a right
epidural hematoma here
that's compressing the
right side of the brain
and what's happening
is the right side is
being shifted over and
you have a subfalcine
herniation which is
where your cingulate
gyrus herniates down
under the foc cerebri
and it's basically
shifting most of the brain
to the other side and
you can also see the
ventricles being
shifted. So you have this
midline imaginary
line, which is from the
sagittal suture to the
sagittal suture, you
can see that red line.
However, your midline
here, your foc cerebri
and your septum
pellucidum, which is this
thin line between your
lateral ventricles,
your thin membrane that
separates your lateral
ventricles, that's
also usually midline,
that's also shifted to
the left side. So
that's the yellow line.
So you basically take
the measurement between
that sagittal suture
line, that imaginary
line, and that is your
midline shift. And you
want to record it over
time to see if the
midline shift is getting
bigger and bigger,
which means the compression,
that mass effect
is getting bigger.
And if it's getting
lesser, that means,
okay, the mass effect is
resolving, the hematoma
is resolving. So this
is a huge clinical
thing that you will see.
And during any kind
of herniation, since
there's a space
occupying, there's
a new volume
occupying that skull,
there's going to be an
increase in intracranial
pressure. So you'll
have symptoms
such as headache,
nausea, vomiting,
photophobia, phonophobia.
Those are certain
symptoms that happens
with increased
intracranial pressure.
And not only does the
brain parenchyma, and
in this case, it's the
cingulate gyrus that's
getting compressed
and will have injury
to the brain itself,
the protruded or the
herniated brain can
compress on other
neurovascular structures.
So specifically for
cephalcine herniation,
the cingulate
gyrus, which runs
right on top of your
corpus callosum,
imagine this is your
your cingulate gyrus
runs on top of it,
and you have this
artery, the pericolosal
artery, pericolosal
meaning peri near the
callosum, corpus callosum,
which is a branch
of anterior cerebral
artery. So often during
cephalcine herniation,
the herniation of
the cingulate gyrus, you
can have the pericolosal
artery getting
compressed and you'll
have symptoms relating
to that which usually
is contralateral leg
weakness. So not only
is the brain parenchyma
itself getting
compressed, it can go
and compress on other
important neurovascular
structures and cause
ischemia or compression
of important nerves.
The second of the
brain herniations is
the transtentorial
herniation or the uncle
herniation. Again,
uncus is the medial
portion of the
temporal lobe that can
herniate through the
tentorium cerebellum
down. You can either have
downward transventory
herniation,
there's also upward
transventory herniation,
but that's usually
cerebellar tonsils
that herniate upward.
One important thing to
keep in mind is that
the uncus can herniate
down on the ipsilateral
side of the hematoma
or neoplasm or any
kind of space-occupying
lesion. So in this
example, you have the
CT head. What you're
seeing is on the right
side, you have a chronic
subjural hematoma
that's compressing this
whole temporal lobe,
and mainly the medial
temporal lobe, the
uncas, is herniating into
that space through the
tentorium cerebellum.
And you can see you
have the oculomotor
nerve that's going through
in that region that
compresses the oculomotor
nerve. So a big
clinical thing that you
look out for that is
a neurosurgical emergency
is the blown pupil
that happens. So
anytime somebody has any
kind of space occupying
lesion, usually a
subdural hematoma or
epidural hematoma that
causes transtentorial
herniation, the uncle
herniation that
compresses the oculomotor
nerve, you'll see the
ipsilateral pupils of that
person being blown,
meaning it's highly
dilated. Remember,
your oculomotor nerve
contains the parasympathetic
fibers that cause
constriction of the
pupils. So if there is a
compression of that
oculomotor nerve, then
there is no constriction
with the light. So
the pupil will remain
dilated when you flash
lights. So you can look
at this patient. You
can see the right eye
is completely fine.
It's fully dilated. So
when you flash a light,
it should constrict,
but it remains fixed,
meaning it is not
constricting to light
and it remains dilated.
And usually we say
greater than five
millimeters. So you usually
use a pen light and it
has numbers that you
can measure the pupil
diameter. So greater
than five millimeter
is considered a blown
pupil. And that is a
neurosurgical emergency
because even before you
even take the CT scan,
you know that this
patient's had a traumatic
brain injury and has a
bleed that is causing
an ankle herniation
that's compressing
the oculomotor nerve.
So there's intracranial
pressure that's being
built up and this
patient needs to be taken
to the OR emergently.
And we usually do a
craniectomy, basically
take off the skull in
that region, let the
brain, so you're
basically opening up that
closed skull space
so that the brain can
accommodate for the edema
that's about to ensue.
And finally,
we have the
transforuminal herniation.
This is when you
have the tonsils of
the cerebellum. And
sometimes it can
be the medulla and
the brainstem itself
that herniate down
through the foramen
magnum. So here
we have a T1 MRI.
I know this is a
T1-weighted MRI
because in T1, your
fluid, your CSF is
black. In a T2 MRI,
your CSF is white.
So in a T1 MRI, You
can see the tonsils
that are herniating
down through
this big cavity,
the foramen magnum.
And this can be,
again, due to some
kind of space
-occupying lesion,
mostly in the posterior
fosa below the
tentorium that's
compressing down.
And this is usually
a poor prognosis in
patients because
anytime you have a
brainstem injury,
you have the centers
of breathing and
consciousness and
alertness, those are
reduced and the patient
is often uptunded,
which is a reduced
level of awareness
or consciousness.
We'll quickly talk
about two meningeal
pathologies or meningeal
lesions and infections.
Again, I'll cover this
in more detail in the
cerebrovascular pathology
lecture later. So
we have the meningioma,
the most common
primary brain tumor, and
this is a benign well
-circumscribed slow
-growing tumor. So the
classic board question,
level one, step one, is
that the patient has
a chronic headache.
They come in, do a MRI.
The MRI shows a small
circumscribed homogenous
supratentorial
mass. Don't even
think about it. It's
menageoma. So menageomas,
90% of them are
supratentorial above
the tentorium cerebelly
that happens. And in
an MRI with contrast,
so again, this is a
T1 rated MRI because
the ventricles where
the CSF is black, if
this was white, then
it's T2. So in this
T1 rated MRI, you
see this homogenous,
there's no heterogeneity.
It's all smooth and
same, and it's well
circumscribed. And
the main thing that you
look for to distinguish
the meningioma is
what's called the
dural tail. So because
these are lesions
of the meninges, the
arachnoid and the dura,
you will see it light
up a little bit,
kind of exactly
what it says. It's
a tail that you
see because the
dura lights up. And
that's a classic
presentation of
the meningioma.
Meningitis is the
inflammation of the
pia and arachnoid
layer. So the pia and
arachnoid together
are called the
leptomeninges. So it's
in an MRI or in a CT
here that you
have, you'll see
leptomeningeal enhancement.
And that's because
of the inflammation
causing the edema.
So you'll have
enhancement that way.
And this is often
caused by gram-negative
bacteria, but it can
also be viral or fungal.
And remember, the
meninges, the dura
arachnoid, and the pia
also extends down to
the spinal cord, so you
can have the meningitis
extends from the spinal
cord itself. And the
patient's present
with fever, headache,
nuchal rigidity, that's
the neck rigidity, and
you guys will learn
about the Brudinsky
and the Koenig sign.
That's when you ask the
patient to flex their
neck because the the
meninges goes all the way
down to the spinal
cord, it's irritated and
the patient will kind
of come into the fetal
position because
there's pain that's
elicited from the
inflammation of the meninges.
And often you do a
lumbar puncture because
now that the blood
-brain barrier has
been compromised in
meningitis, you will
see the CSF has bacteria
and cell culture.
It will normalize to the
plasma cell components.
So take a couple
of minutes
and read through
this question.
This kind of
recaps the brain
herniations that
we went through.
So this patient
clearly requires
neurosurgical
intervention immediately.
So the CT scan is
showing a clear right
subdural hematoma,
a chronic subdural
hematoma that's causing
uncle herniation,
right? The transcentral
herniation down the
tentorium cerebellum.
And because the stem
says that he has a
dilated, unresponsible
right pupil of six
millimeter, right?
He has a blown pupil,
compression of the
oculomotor nerve,
right? And that is a
neurosurgical emergency,
as we said before.
So he's having a
uncle herniation and
it needs an initial
urgent neurosurgical
intervention
where you'll do a
craniectomy and
relieve that pressure.
So this is like a
second degree question
that you can expect
on your comp as
well as your level
one and step one.
So we'll shift gears
now and talk about
the ventricular system.
So the ventricular
system was first
ever defined by the
great Leonardo da
Vinci, who's known to be
an artist, but he also
was a great anatomist
and drew diagrams
of skeletal system,
muscular system,
and as well as the
brain. So in the early
1500s, we have records
of him, his
ventriculography, where he
went into, reported
to have went into a
butcher shop and
injected hot vax
into a dead ox's
skull. And after the
vax set, he took
it out. so he was
able to create that
ventriculography.
The VACs filled up
the reservoirs inside
the ventricles and
he was able to draw
it. So that's the
first ever documented
drawing of a
ventricular system. It
would have been
great if you guys got
the lecture on
ventricular system from
Da Vinci, but not
to worry because
you will be getting
it from Da Vinci.
i know that was bad
but um bear with me
guys we have about 10
more slides to go so
let's talk about the
ventricular system
so the ventricular
system is a connected
network of cavities in
the brain so it contains
uh and flow has
flowing css through it
all the time so you
have the css in the
subarachnoid space
that is cushioning and
nourishing the brain but
then you have separately
you have the css
most of it collected
in the ventricular
system. And the ventricles
are aligned by ependymal
cells, which are
glial cells. Remember
the special epithelial
cells of the choroid
plexus that forms
that blood CSF barrier
so that the CSF in
the ventricles are not
in contact with the
blood vessels. So
you have two lateral
ventricles, one in each
of the cerebrum, right
you have two lateral
ventricles they're
interconnected to the
third ventricle which
is midline in the
diencephalon in the thalamus
the two thalamus
comes together in the
midline is your third
ventricle and then
you have the fourth
ventricle in the hind
brain and from the
fourth ventricle you have
these lateral rhesus
that connects the
ventricles to the
subarachnoid space that way
we'll talk about each
of these individually
and their anatomy in
the next few slides
the first and the
largest part of the
ventricular system is your
lateral ventricles which
is present in either
each of the cerebral
hemispheres so you have
the lateral ventricle
here so this is a CT
head axial cut and
the lateral ventricles
have three horns and
a body so here you can
see the anterior horn
or the frontal horn
as seen here and then
you have the body of
the lateral ventricles
which is the biggest
portion. And then you
have the occipital horn
or the posterior horn,
and you have the
temporal horn or the
inferior horn. The
temporal horn is present in
the temporal lobe,
and you really don't
usually see that in a
CT scan. And if you do
see that, that's usually
in the setting of
ventriculomegaly in the
setting of hydrocephalus,
which we will talk
about in the future.
And these lateral
ventricles, they're
separate from each other,
and they're separated
through this thin sheet
of membrane called
the septum pellucidum.
I mentioned septum
pellucidum when talking
about sepfalcine
or cingulate herniation.
Remember, it's
also referred to as
the midline shift, and
the midline shift
can be measured from
how the septum pellucidum
gets compressed
and the ventricle system
gets compressed to
the other side, the
contralateral side of
the bleed, and that's
how you measure it.
This is another picture
showing the lateral
ventricle here, this
opening, this is a mid
-sagittal cadaveric
picture. You can
appreciate these white
matter tracts that form
the anterior and superior
roof of the lateral
ventricle. That is your
big corpus callosum,
the white matter tract
that communicates
your left and right
cerebral hemispheres.
And inferiorly, you
have the white matter
tract of the fornix
that forms the
inferior wall. And
the lateral ventricle
connects to the third
ventricle through
this opening here
called the foramen of
Monroe or the
interventricular foramen.
So you have two
foramen of Monroe
that connects
the two lateral
ventricles into the
third ventricle.
Connecting from the
lateral ventricles
is your second part
of the ventricular
system which is the
third ventricle. So
again this is the mid
-sagital cut in the
cadaveric picture. You
guys will get familiar
with this image
very, very quickly.
This is all of the
stuff that you see here
you will need to memorize
and understand at
one point. So again,
you have the lateral
ventricles connecting
into the third ventricle
through that
interventricular foramen or
the foramen of Monroe.
And the third ventricle
is between. So you
have your two thalami
on the left and the
right and they come
together and that cavity
formed, that mid-median
slit-like cavity formed
by the thalamus and
your hypothalamus,
which is right here,
part of the hypothalamus,
that is your third
ventricle, and there's
one third ventricle.
You actually have this
connection between
the thalamus that
goes through the
median connection called
the ***** intermedia
or the interthalamic
adhesion that
kind of goes through
the third ventricle.
The third ventricle
then connects to the
fourth ventricle
through this very narrow
conduit called the
aqueduct of sylvius or
the sylvian aqueduct.
You can see how small
it is compared to
the rest of the third
ventricle. And this
is a, because of the
narrowness of it, often
you can have obstructive
hydrocephalus from
a clot or bleed or
some kind of mass
obstructing the flow of
the third ventricle
from the flow of the
CSF from third
ventricle and the fourth
ventricle. So then the
CSF gets built up in
the third ventricle and
the lateral ventricle,
and you can have
ventricular megaly.
And other structures
to appreciate here,
you have the optic
chiasm that kind of forms
the anterior border.
You have the lamina
terminalis here,
which is the actual
anterior wall of the
third ventricle. Remember,
we talked about the
organum vasculosum
of the lamina
terminalis, one of the
circumventricular organs,
which is right here.
You have, here is your
infundibulum and the
pituitary, remember
the posterior pituitary
or the neurohypophysis,
which is another
circumventricular
organ. You can also have
the median eminence,
which is here, another
circumventricular organs.
Just kind of doing
a little review of what
we learned. And you
also have the pineal
gland posterior to it,
which is another
circumventricular organ.
The CSF from the third
ventricle then flows
through the aqueduct
of sylvius into the
fourth ventricle,
which is between your
cerebellum and your
brainstem. So that's
your final big portion
of the ventricular
system. The CSF then
can also flow through
the central canal
of medulla into the
spinal cord. Remember,
the brain and spinal
cord is in continuation
with each other.
From here, from the
fourth ventricle, you
actually have three
openings that connects
the subarachnoid
space, that connects
the ventricles into
the subarachnoid space.
So you have from the
fourth ventricle,
you have a median opening
called the foramen
of Magendi, and you
have two lateral
opening called the
foramen of Lushka, which
allows the CSF
to flow from the
ventricular
system into the
subarachnoid space.
So this is where
that blood CSF
barrier is not present
because it's an actual
opening from the ventricles
into the subarachnoid
space. The CSF
then flows around
the brain through the
subarachnoid space and
then they will connect
into the sinuses
through arachnoid
granulation or villi
which we will talk about.
The cerebrospinal fluid
surrounds the brain
and mainly surrounds
the brain and the
spinal cord as it is
in continuum and mainly
acts as a shock
absorber. So you have the
cranium the very strong
skull that mainly
acts as a protection
for the brain, but then
the brain is suspended
in this fluid that
is able to absorb a
lot of the shock and
prevent harmful traumatic
injury to the brain.
But there has been
also, the CSF has been
theorized to have
immunological function
similar to the lymphatic
system of the brain,
which is called the
glymphatic system.
This is more of a new
system that has been
found in the last
couple of years. There's
a lot of research
that's being done on it.
I'm not too
familiar with it.
That's why I'm
not going to go
too deep into it.
But the CSF has been
theorized to have
similar functions as
the glymphatic system.
But what it is, is it
is an ultrafiltrate of
the plasma, of the
blood plasma. So we know
that the blood plasma
has this much ratio
of RBCs by blood cells,
proteins. So similar
to that, the CSF is an
ultrafiltrate of it.
So it has very, very
little, one or two
that you can count,
red blood cells, white
blood cells, and
proteins. And the CSF is
produced by the choroid
plexus cells that line
the ventricles,
specifically the lateral
ventricles, and you'll
see mostly in the third
ventricle and the
fourth ventricle. So a
person, on average,
produces 500 ml per day of
CSF, And they circulate
within the lateral
ventricles, starting
from the lateral
ventricles, connecting to
the third ventricle via
the foramen of Monroe,
and into the fourth
ventricle through the
aqueduct of Silvius.
And then from the
fourth ventricle,
it has free
connection to the
spinal cord from
the medullary canal.
And from the lateral,
from the ventricles,
it connects to the
subarachnoid space via
the three recesses that
we talked about. So
laterally, you have the
two foramen of Lushka,
and medially, you
have the foramen of
Munro that connects the
ventricles, CSF from
the ventricles into
the subarachnoid space.
From the subarachnoid
space, it flows
through and into the
superior sagittal
sinus via the
arachnoid villi, which
we will talk about
in the next slide.
So once the CSF travels
from the ventricles
into the subarachnoid
space through the
foramen of Magendi and
Lushka, it travels through
the subarachnoid space
and nourishes and
suspends the brain and
the fluid, and then
it gets reabsorbed,
right? It cannot stay in
that same system. It's
continuously circulating,
and it gets reabsorbed
into the body's
circulatory system via
this outpouching of
the arachnoid membrane.
So you have your
arachnoid here, and
the arachnoid membrane
outpouches into the
superior sagittal
sinus mainly. And this
is called arachnoid
granulations or the
arachnoid villi. That's
where the CSF gets
dumped into the
sinuses. And from the
sinuses, it will travel
into the venous system
and back into the
heart where it gets
then pumped into the
lungs and gets
reoxygenated and then the
arachnoid, the choroid
plexus keeps making
more CSF from the
ultrafiltrated plasma.
So here's another
schema of showing
how the CSF
flows from this
arachnoid space
through the arachnoid
villi into the
venous sinuses.
I want to quickly
touch up on certain
pathologies of the
ventricular system all of
these will be in
detail covered in the
cerebrovascular pathology
lecture later so what
we have what's called
the choroid plexus
tumors these are rare
benign tumors of the
choroid plexus cells
that line the ventricles
and these tumors cause
overproduction of
the CSF and so you can
imagine you have buildup
of overproduction,
overproduced CSF,
which then makes the
ventricles look bigger.
And that's what's
called ventriculomegaly.
So this is a T1
-weighted MRI. And I know
this is T1 because
the fluid, the CSF, is
black. If the CSF in
the ventricles were
white, that would be
a T2-weighted MRI.
And you can look at
this and see, this
is huge ventricles.
And on the right,
you can see the
third ventricle here
and the fourth
ventricles are so big,
and the occipital
hones are so big. So
there's just
tentraventriculomegaly.
Another pathology is
the intraventricular
hemorrhage, which
is hemorrhage within
the ventricle. It
can either be primary
where the hemorrhage
starts within the
ventricles. That's
usually seen in preterm
babies where they
have the germinal
centers within the
ventricles that hemorrhage.
We'll talk about it
in later lectures.
Or it could be a
secondary intraventricular
hemorrhage, which
is usually an
extension from an
intracerebral hemorrhage.
And finally, you have
ventriculitis. This
is the inflammation of
the ependymal cells.
Those are the special
endothelial cells of
the choroid plexus that
line the ventricles.
And you can see the
white enhancement,
which is from the edema
from the inflammation,
and this can be from
an infection or a post
-traumatic or implant
-related meningitis.
The final pathology
of the ventricular
system that we'll talk
about is hydrocephalus,
which is basically
an abnormal
accumulation of the CSF
within the ventricles
of the brain, and
there are two primary
mechanisms by which
this can happen. One is
because there is
a problem with the
absorption of CSF from
the ventricular system.
And the other one
is there's an actual
overproduction
of CSF. So either
problem with absorbing
it or a problem
with too much CSF
overproduction.
And we already
talked about the
overproduction, which
only makes up very
smaller cases of the
hydrocephalus. And it
can be from the choroid
plexus papilloma,
which we talked about
in the last slide. So
mostly hydrocephalus
is caused by subnormal
CSF reabsorption. And
this can happen by
two mechanisms.
There's the obstructive
hydrocephalus, which
is actually, there's a
mechanical obstruction of
the flow of CSF through
the ventricular
system that we talked
about. And the other
one is there's an actual
problem that's blocking
the reabsorption
of CSF from the
subarachnoid space into the
venous system. So
with the obstructive
hydrocephalus, you
usually observe it,
obstruction of the sylvian
duct. We talked about
how the sylvian duct
is the narrowest
portion in the
ventricular system. So if
there is any clot or
any mass or anything,
any tumor, intraventricular
hemorrhage,
anything like that, that
blocks the flow, then
you have proximal to
the blockage, you'll
have ventriculomegaly
and hydrocephalus
and distilled to the
blockage of wherever
it is in the ventricular
system, you'll have
actually smaller
ventricles. So here on
the MRI, this is a T1
-weighted MRI. Again,
I know this is T1
-weighted because the
CSF in the ventricles
are black. If it was
white, then it would
be a T2-weighted MRI.
I know I keep talking
about this. This
is just so that you
guys get used to it.
So you actually have
a colloid cyst that's
blocking the
intraventricular foramen,
which connects your
lateral ventricle into
the third ventricle,
and what you end up
having is the
ventriculomegaly of the
lateral ventricles. So
this is an obstructive
hydrocephalus, aka
non-communicating
hydrocephalus. In a
communicating hydrocephalus
or non-obstructive
hydrocephalus, the
problem usually lies
within the arachnoid
villi or the arachnoid
granulation. So
there's something
obstructing it or that has
destroyed the arachnoid
granulation so that
the CSF cannot be
reabsorbed from the
subarachnoid space
into the venous system.
And this usually
happens with meningitis
trauma or subarachnoid
hemorrhage. So
in this picture,
again, a T1-rated MRI,
this is a patient
who had subarachnoid
hemorrhage and then later
on started developing
hydrocephalus,
which is a common
complication of
subarachnoid hemorrhage. And
you can see dilation
of the lateral
ventricles. And I want
you guys to pay attention.
You're seeing the
temporal horns of
the lateral ventricle.
I mentioned that
usually you don't see
the temporal horns.
And if you do, that is
a sign of hydrocephalus
and ventriculomegaly.
And you can
also see dilation of
the third ventricle.
And this is probably
due to the blood
in this subarachnoid
space that probably
either obstructed
the arachnoid
granulation or
completely destroyed it.
And finally, I just
want to mention some
other miscellaneous
pathologies that result
in hydrocephalus,
none of which actually
kind of goes with
the two mechanisms of
hydrocephalus that I
mentioned in the last
slide. So we have what's
called the hydrocephalus
X vacuole. So in
this picture on the
right, again, T1 rated
MRI, you see that
ventriculomegaly. But
this is not actually
due to there's an
overproduction of CSF
or problem with the
reabsorption. This is
actually because there
is the atrophy of the
brain that then
makes the ventricles
bigger. So it looks like
there's ventriculomegaly
and you often see
that with Alzheimer's
patients. There's
the cortical atrophy.
And another pathology
is called normal
pressure hydrocephalus
or NPH, a
heavily tested
topic on the boards.
This is the actual
mechanism of
hydrocephalus, not
fully understood, but
usually when you have
hydrocephalus, you
have buildup of CSF,
which then causes
high intracranial
pressure and patients
usually have
symptoms of high ICP.
But with NPH, the
pressure is normal,
and this is often seen
in older adults and
comes with a triad of
urinary incontinence,
cognitive dysfunction,
and gait abnormality,
often known as wet,
walkie, and wobbly.
And finally, you have
a pathology called
pseudotumor cerebris,
which is seen
in young females.
It's also known as
idiopathic intracranial
hypertension.
Again, the actual
mechanism is not fully
understood, but this is,
again, a hydrocephalus
that results in
high intracranial
pressure without an
identifiable mass or
obstruction in the brain.
And the patients usually
complain of classic
headache, transient
visual loss, pulsatile
tinnitus, and
dizziness. And the
management usually depends
on draining the CSF
using a lumbar drain.
So you're trying to
relieve that intracranial
pressure by taking
out some of the CSF.
So that was the
end of the lecture.
Here is your summary
slide. I want you
guys to look through
each of these
pictures and ask
yourself, are you able
to fully describe
what this picture
is and what this
pathology is? If you
are, then you are
good for my lecture.
For those who stuck out
until the end, thank
you so much. You guys
are troopers. I know
this was a long and
heavy lecture, but make
sure you go through the
slides over and over
again. And if you guys
have any questions
and want to Zoom or
have emails to send,
please email me at my
email is right here. and
also if you're
someone interested in
neurosurgery and wants to
get involved in research
and actually do
participate in surgery so
this is me actually
evacuating a subdural
hematoma email me we have
a lot of opportunities
I work at St. Barnabas
Hospital and also
please take time to
fill out the lecture
feedback form so that
I know how to improve
my future lectures.
Good luck, guys.